today we're talking about C++ data flow
and bigquery
I'm Stephanie Wong and welcome to this
week in cloud where we serve you the
lowest latency news we are now building
C++ client libraries for all Google
cloud services many of you are already
using the C++ libraries for cloud
storage and BigTable and we hear your
requests for more we've just released a
beta version of the cloud spanner C++
library and we're actively working on
open source client libraries for all of
the remaining cloud services dataflow is
Google clouds fully managed batch and
stream data processing service and it
now includes throughput and CPU
utilization charts that will help you
diagnose and remediate your pipeline
issues with the better observability you
can spend less time fixing problems and
more time getting value out of your data
bigquery is a server list highly
scalable and cost-effective cloud data
warehouse it's designed to be flexible
and easy to use so that you make a few
decisions at the start and bigfry
handles the work for you in this post
one of our engines explains how zone
assignments work in big free and covers
best practices for organizing your data
speaking of learning we've released the
session guide for Google cloud next
twenty twenty in San Francisco on April
6th through the 8th registration is open
now and you can even plan your journey
by checking out the over 500 sessions we
will be offering happy scrolling if you
want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud
you